music we ask you only to give us a part
of you part of your identity
oh okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to mere layers I
was looking for the option menu oh oh no
I created a new directory in your
Documents folder that collects
informations about your personality I
don't know if I consented to that Oh so
please share them with the world some
tasks need real cooperation to be solved
use a computer if you need help don't be
shy I don't know if you're gonna give me
the option of being shy or not hi
welcome to this game I didn't know that
I was starting already so this is mirror
layers and supposedly this is a game
that messes with you and now I'm
starting to see why and who and how oh
jeez oh oh oh I did
so hello welcome to mirror layers I'm
actually gonna hit play now oh okay
alright so supposedly this is a game
that messes with you and it creep wait
hang on before I even get started here I
gotta see isn't there's a message in my
this is the game folder oh oh there it
is statue input a ho statue output oh
boy oh okay alright then thanks buddy
oh I'm so happy about this oh no oh no
oh okay oh jeez command list help but oh
oh oh boy
this is literally a public group about
mere layers I finished it it was amazing
I really like the way the computer in
the game affects my real computer in
real life when I type documents into the
prompt in the game it opens up the files
on my computer what when I type in help
it brings me to this page Oh
Oh tape that says dad forever needs it
what what does that mean oh no does
anybody have key to have key 300 oh my
god that's amazing that's amazing
I don't remember my dur tapping door oh
yeah it goes at the Documents folder
holy [ __ ] oh my god that's so cool okay
and also moderately terrifying so I
think I prefaced everything that I
needed to preface in this game it's
basically a game that just dicks with
you the whole time is that that is
actually what time it is in my my real
life here so oh that's so bizarre oh
there's so weird
okay down here a drippy drop e okay I
just hear a lot of tick tocking and I
don't know what else going on oh boy oh
boy oh nice shoes
hi
okay hello hi how are you oh you have
boobs and no arms and no face a
connection between this world and the
one you're living in oh okay alright
then
oh no oh no the [ __ ] was that I'm
hearing a lot of noises for being here
hopefully by myself can i knife someone
can I pick up the knife can I
does that me was that me
that wasn't hey this is ready pick up a
broom oh god no okay so it seems okay
though so far oh boy oh boy
oh it's dead end oh I just have a dead
end in my house worried about me hello I
thought you were Cthulhu oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy okay
so I need to have a bit more intelligent
commentary than just oh boy
why do I have no reflect
[Music]
hi hi hello oh no ok are you dad
you better be dead I hope your dad I
mean that's a weird thing for me to say
but you know what I just oh jeez oh jeez
Scoob
oh hello hi oh it's a mirror world I get
it I can't use his computer his
computers off am I alone here that's the
biggest question on my mind what the
hell is that hmm
Leggett oh god oh god this hello I have
these hello for I don't know hello thank
you I have I got a four are there four
boxes jeez
[ __ ] stop just stop okay so I found
the four box oh god these clocks are all
wrong
that's not my time time doesn't exist in
this place oh what's that
I got a to the farm sorry doll [ __ ] is
that
oh hi you're not the Grim Reaper or
Cthulhu oh boy oh boy oh [ __ ] god damn
it [ __ ] [ __ ]
me what is that hey what is that is that
her is another thing I need to know
right now is that not playing what the
[ __ ] oh my god okay all right
everything's fine I spat a lot more than
I intended to and also I expected today
to be a void where my voice could
recover I haven't even talked you guys
this whole time I've been a bit
preoccupied with not dying oh oh god
what's on my screen
oh no oh Jesus can I put this oh there
we go okay oh okay you're just gonna
ignore all the random text on my screen
oh no help me oh geez oh no oh man what
does that mean does anybody have key - I
have key - oh oh I get it I get it
does anybody have key - I have key three
I have key - I have box for I need key
for I have key - oh man oh that's so
crazy how do I give them key - how do I
give key - I have Keowee all keys here
key - is loneliness stop mirror that's
that's a bit risky clicking on a random
download link I'll do it though I'll do
it for you guys cuz I love you let me
let me do a little antivirus you know
protection if you're gonna be playing
this game and I highly recommend you do
definitely watch what you download be
very careful out there scan it before
you open it all that stuff
oh no whose fries
mean please oh god please let me live
near your world I only want to I don't
know what that means I don't know what
that means
but I need key for so I put this in
input is it the sound of something crawl
through one of my beers or is that good
so if the statue oh oh my god
oh my I didn't even restart my game oh
my god at a connection between this
world and the one you were in that makes
so much sense that's so cool that is
ludicrously cool what the hell
so if I put wait I have an idea if I put
my key but if I throw it in the statue
transfer to world what Oh
oh my god it's there what that's so cool
oh man I'm losing my voice already oh my
god that is the coolest that is that is
one of the most unique things I've ever
seen in a game let alone a horror game
but now the problem is I have to go back
into the mirror oh I don't wanna I don't
have a reflection but Mikey do hey why
am I here why am I here okay I'm just
gonna put it in the box
oh god hello hi who am i staring in the
face of death yeah
okay here we go
Oh what why do I have a lag why do I
have a lag Oh long leg Larry we're gonna
go on a [ __ ] up adventure long leg
Larry I have a funny feeling I know who
owns you oh don't worry I'm gonna adopt
you long leg Larry look out for the next
charity stream whoo we got the exclusive
Blasi for long leg Larry Oh God uh I'm
pressing E you want it or not
oh [ __ ] god damn it okay Oh Oh all is
good is that the end of the game did I
do it is that all I needed to do that
couldn't have been all I needed to do oh
oh no oh no oh no I gotta go back Donna
oh no oh boy
dad here dog barking okay so Larry's
gone
so uh hi oh boy
hi oh hi how are you doing oh oh okay
you know what okay so you're missing an
arm I have a funny feeling I know how
this is gonna go
Oh what is this oh it's code board oh no
that means that other people are gonna
have the code but I don't have the code
okay so it's a four-character code yeah
hi
so there's got to be there's got to be
something in here that I have ill that
other people do not have that's got to
be the thing right that's how this works
so if I have if or if I if I have
something that I'm the [ __ ] is that
oh my god oh my god
ah man my voice is not gonna keep up
through this oh no I do not know what
that was but it was different than the
other one I don't want to know I'm a
brave boy I'm a big brave boy god
okay so ah of course I should go back
here geez go back here to where ok so
there's nothing here anymore so it's not
here
unless it's here there's got to be like
a code written on the walls or maybe on
the computer
hey on one side on the computer no damn
just oh what's that father father
oh D oh D I don't have anything to write
down with D ok I'll remember D I get it
D D 1
[Music]
sameen are there more tapes in here I've
got a D but that doesn't help me unless
it's like I've got one letter and maybe
I need to submit that it's apparently
either fifty I [ __ ] but if I can Oh God
oh [ __ ] again oh no no no no no no [ __ ]
up well oh [ __ ] god dammit
oh okay so what I'm getting out of this
[ __ ] is that I'm probably gonna go die
the next time I go in there but I've got
a D so what I think it needs to happen
is I actually need you guys's help on
this one I I'm gonna end this episode
here I'm actually out of time but what I
need you guys to do is I need you to
play this game with me I legitimately
need you guys to play this game with me
because this is [ __ ] incredible like
this is actually legitimately
mind-blowing right now this is so cool
so I'm gonna put a link to the
description in the description to the
game where you can download it and just
remember like I said when you're sharing
files be very careful though download
just anything always scan with your
antivirus before you open it but just
this is cool and I need you guys help
with this one because I literally cannot
finish this game by myself also my voice
may not keep up with me but let me know
what you think down the comments below
let me know what you find down the
comments below and I'm gonna get out of
here before I somehow die because I have
a I have a sneaking suspicion that the
longer I play in this area I might dies
while here so thank you everybody so
much for watching I look forward to your
input on this very soon and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye